I love driving checkers easy to get in
and easy to get out of after I do a
little work on them it's easy to get on
the freeway and go 8090 miles an hour
with them and sit there and keep up with
traffic not that you'd ever get that
chance in LA or New York my name is Joe
Pollard and I own checkered parts
checkers probably are the most iconic
American car worldwide and most
recognizable if it's painted yellow I do
parts for checkers I steal parts off of
old cars and sell them to people and
restore checkers and just about anything
to do with the checker I actually got
started in this in 1978 I got my first
checker after riding in them for years
as a musician moving my drums around
different cities I didn't know that
they'd quit making them and couldn't
find parts and I started making parts
for them so for example I remade all the
fenders in fiberglass I pretty much
remade all the suspension and steering
parts because those were unique to
checker
I make thousands of parts at this point
[Music]
my best guess on cars left in the world
is from between 2,500 and 3,000 total
there's a variety of owners from hotrod
tankers to movie stars I've got a car
that used to belong to Sylvester
Stallone at one point they'll be worth a
lot of money
I was up to 400 cars about two years ago
and decided it was time to start
cleaning house I'm down to about 150
cars now I just can't seem to quit
collecting them it's a sickness I'm not
a hoarder honest and the scope of things
some years the movie industry is 80
percent of my income other years it's
two or three this car was recently in
Jersey boys and x-men first class and
anchorman 2 for catch me if you can we
painted this car three times during the
run of the show because each city was a
different color codes this is a 1965
checker they made less than ten of these
this year most people don't even know
checker made a station wagon I've been
doing it for about 30 years making parts
and selling parts and stuff and I love
it to death it's kind of my retirement
because playing drums I had no
retirement I just have a ball with it
[Music]